Speaker 1: Let's go next to Tina from Asheville,
North Carolina. Tina, how are you?
Speaker 5: Oh, my God.
Speaker 1: All right now, Tina, if we're going
to talk, you've got to turn off that notification
noise because it is just it's going to destroy any
ability you and I have to communicate. So you've
got to turn off notifications and discord.
Speaker 5: Tina. Can you hear me now, David?
Speaker 1: I can still hear you, but those are
still continuing to blink, if you can turn off
notifications, that would be great.
Speaker 5: Oh gosh, I don't know
how to do that. This is my first time on
Discord. Oh dear. OK. It's still blinking.
Speaker 1: It hasn't for now.
Speaker 5: OK. OK. I think it
was me because I didn't know if I was meeting
or UN meeting. OK. OK. Long time subscriber,
first time caller. Thank you for picking on
me, and I just actually wanted to ask you
about how, like, how to speak about Hispanic
people. And I just wanted to know like what the
difference is between like Latin. Like if you're
talking about Hispanic people in this country,
do you refer to them as Latino or is Hispanic OK?
I mean, I know you're Argentinian, so I'm just
wondering like, which one is is more acceptable?
Speaker 1: Listen, there are people who feel
very, very strongly about this, and they say
the right word is Hispanic, but not Latino.
The right word is Latino, but not Hispanic.
There are people who say that these words
have different definitions. Like, for example,
Hispanic would include Spain, but not Brazil,
whereas Latino would include all of Latin America,
but not Spain, with Brazil maybe being part of it,
or maybe not. And there's a couple other countries
in South America that you could argue culturally
or not, not a part of Latin America. I am
not like a big I think both were. I don't
find either word offensive. I understand that
the words may have slightly different meanings.
But if we're all trying to communicate in good
faith, I know what someone means when they refer
to Latino folks and Hispanic folks, and I use both
terms sometimes. So I'm not like a big stickler,
but there's different elements of academia
that would have particular points of view.
And you know, you ask someone else, you'll get a
different answer to, you know, that's the truth.
Speaker 5: OK. All right,
thank you so much, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. There's
Tina from Asheville, North Carolina,
with a number of different technical aspects of
the call that dramatically improved as we went.
Let's go next to D. B. from Virginia.
Am I pronouncing that right, Debbie?
Speaker 2: Delap, yeah, can't you? Yes, I can
get him, yes, I can. Oh, what's up, man? How
you doing? Good. How are you? The only reason
they're so I'm watching the case, it looks like.
Speaker 1: Look, you're cutting out, Deb, so
you said to me, you're watching the case and
it looks like and then you cut out right
when you were saying what it looks like.
Speaker 2: Is vastly different to me,
Speaker 1: 50-50 in terms of all the charges
or on them on the homicide.
Speaker 2:
Like, yeah, all the stars is pretty much.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I'm just not sure. I mean, how
how is the prosecution going to eliminate from the
jury's belief that Rittenhouse really feared for
his life? How are they going to prove to the jury
Speaker 2: that, yeah, that's what I was
thinking. Yeah, yeah, that's what I was
thinking, too. But then again, there's like
people in the gut tell you those days it was like,
This is a United States. If you don't stand so
Speaker 1: well, but hold on a
second people, and it's
Speaker 2: going to be a way
to say it again. Wait, wait, whoa. Whoa.
Speaker 1: Rosenbaum didn't have a gun,
right? Rosenbaum didn't point a gun at a Kyle
Rittenhouse. The argument that Rittenhouse
makes is that after the first shot, Rosenbaum
attempted to grab the gun. We're already kind
of in the weeds, but I still see it as a big hill
to overcome, to say he didn't fear for his life.
Speaker 2: But yet this judge is crazy, man.
Speaker 1: The judges are just crazy,
the judges out there. Yeah. I mean, listen, I
know it early, Jimi. Earlier, Jimi from Philly
said the judge is actually trying to help the
prosecution. I don't see that at all. I see the
judge interrupting on the day of the Rittenhouse
testimony, five or six times at key moments where
Rittenhouse was sort of falling apart. I see the
decisions mostly favoring the defense. I see the
judge more of as an as an asset to the defense.
Speaker 2: Yeah, so it was like. And another
thing and smart thing outside of this job. Joe
Vladimir, I feel sorry Larry passed this year,
man, I live in Virginia. Yeah.
Slaughter and slaughter bloodbath. Oh,
it was. No, it was no signs, but it was bad.
Speaker 1: Wait, but you're saying you're saying
for the young Kim McAuliffe race, right?
Speaker 2: Yes. I was like, nobody voted
that I knew. You know, nobody voted
low turnout in this election now.
Speaker 1: So well, it's Virginia's going to be
a real question mark for Democrats in the next
couple of years. I think that's clear.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah. Well, we'll see.
Speaker 1: All right, what do you think
about? Thank you for the call. Yeah. No,
I think about it. I'm going to let you go
because I have so many people holding great
to speak to you. I do really appreciate
it. We're going to take a very quick break
and then we're going to be right back at it
and take some more phone calls in a moment.